this is exciting for me not just because
i uh genuinely uh
like this man but he also agreed to
appear in person
and he's an actual human being sitting
in a in the show
guest chair uh the only man who could
follow up stephen a smith as the
in-studio guest previous here on the
program we read his stuff on the mmqb
and enjoying his podcast and his
newsletter as well which we'll get into
andrew brant former nfl executive here
in person good to see you sir
great to be here rich you know my son
moved out here a couple years ago he's a
music producer he's doing great
i try to see him as often as i can so
i'm out here in west hollywood and of
course that supreme court case came down
yesterday you reached out to me and like
you can only talk to me but you can
actually see me so sold
it worked out so here i am great to be
with you great to actually do this
i mean i know you take it for granted oh
my god here we are
live in person no mask and we're making
this happen i know science is amazing uh
i'm glad that you are i'm glad that you
are here let's get into that supreme
court case again
and uh it was chewed up and spit out so
much yesterday what's
you're now a day clear and having read
everything including
uh justice kavanaugh's scathing
concurrence where he basically um
told the ncaa that not only did you lose
here today
nine nothing but be careful because
the whole economic model of the ncaa
could be
illegal in antitrust law what do you
make of
of how we might see college athletics
change based on what happened
yeah you know rich for sports law nerds
like me right it's a big day we get
giddy because there are not many of
these cases
the last one was three years ago as you
know when the court ruled sports betting
can be implemented
new jersey started it and now 23 states
have legalized sports betting
this one's about a real limited category
of rights for student athletes but as
you mentioned i'll talk about
much bigger implications so the actual
case said
the nca cannot restrict education
related benefits what's that
tutoring study abroad internships
science equipment computers
you know that kind of in musical
instruments it's kind of benign right
you know okay yeah they opened that up
but as you said
the majority opinion justice gorsuch and
of course the concurring opinion by
justice kavanaugh
were very strident against the ncaa they
basically said
in so many words bring on the next one
and we're going to open this up further
because the ncaa can't rely on these
age-old definition of amateurism
it's just not going to last so college
athletes
are going to have rights beyond this
it's just a matter of when
they said the ncaa is not above the law
you're not going to get any antitrust
exemption
and yes you have to allow more education
related benefits you can't restrict that
as of today schools can start giving
out more science equipment i guess but
the next case is going to be more
because brett kavanaugh
who knew he's the champion of a
student-athlete's rights right
and he says you bring another case
we're going to strike it down any ncaa
rules but let's be clear
this was not a pay-for-play case
everyone's talking about you're going to
pay student athletes you're going to pay
college football and basketball players
no
but the language was the ncaa
is not a monopoly you can't do this
and we're going to allow student
athletes more rights in the next case
and the next case in the next case so
let's just bro let's just break it down
and brass tax it
yeah um nick saban signed a contract
extension through when chris brockman
was it again 2027.
2024 29. will he have
a player getting paid because
that's the way things go in the ncaa by
the end by the time his contract is over
i think so i mean the next two weeks
rich
we haven't even talked about nil name
image likeness revenue for college
athletes it's coming six states
implemented already it's going to start
july 1. the ncaa's have an emergency
meeting today
not related to the case yesterday but
about this name image likeness
because the floodgates are opening july
1.
other schools and states have to react
to florida texas mississippi alabama
doing it
that's going to start july 1. in some
form or fashion
student athletes can get endorsements
again it's not the school's paying
but you go down the street to joe's
chevrolet
yeah the funny guarantees of the world
or friday night lights are going to
basically
say to the star i guess here in
california is one of those states
florida's one of those states
you know like the acla the ucla
quarterback here in town we might see
him for you know some chevrolet
some sort of honda and then nick saban
is going to tell the recruits hey you
come here
freshman year you know maybe you'll get
200 grand in nil
by senior year you're you're making a
million dollars in that because we're
alabama because that's happened already
and that's going to continue this arms
race
in college athletics for the big time i
think bottom line rich
in a number of years we're going to see
two tiers of college athletics one tier
that the nca controls
and all the sports that we don't hear
about much and then big time college
football basketball it's just gonna be
something else
i don't know what it's gonna be but it's
not gonna be nca legislated sports
it's going to be something else more
like pro sports but still have some
elements
of no pay or limited pay
some controls over it was is it tied to
academics in any way shape or form i
think it will be but i think the
restrictions will be loosened big time
and i'm a little conflicted because my
day job is
running a program i know you had gabe
here yesterday on the on the program
i run it at villanova we have 24 sports
one who happened to win two of the last
five ncaa basketball
championships makes money so
yeah i'm conflicted because people think
college sports is
you know college sports is 98
of the athletes aren't going pro so in
some ways that's
good nil can give those players some
modest
income right and you know the trevor
lawrence's and zion's
they're going to be fine but maybe this
helps out the majority
the vast majority of college athletes
andrew brant here in person on the rich
eisen show from the mmqb and what
what are you doing at villanova you run
their their speech yeah there's more
jeff morat he's out here he ran the he
owned the san diego padres he started a
sports business and law center
at villanova okay i teach i run the
program i'm executive director there
former uh front office executive the
green bay packers and we're going to hit
all that
uh here and as you're here for the rest
of the hour on the rich eisen show
so then what how how do we corral this
and uh make this
fair and not not just for the student
athletes but for
the competition because this is the wild
wild west here
you know what i mean where you know one
town and unforgiven you can't bring guns
in
and another town it's not a big problem
you could do whatever the heck you want
to come into this town
and so somebody that already has a big
time
college football or basketball program
says we're in we're in in
an nil positive state right
uh where you can do whatever you want
and other programs don't and then
there's
suddenly scheduling issues and league
issues and conference issues and money
issues and
and then players will will want to
unionize yeah i mean that there will be
somebody who's like let's get you all
together in a room so you can
collectively bargain
with the pac-12 with the big ten
i mean isn't that coming based on coming
in you know we know
college sports is a two-tiered system
already you know you can't compete with
sec football if you're
some mid-major conference but i think
what you've identified
is changes coming and the problem with
the ncaa
and i understand they have a tough job
but they're
only reactive to two things legislation
and litigation
if not for those two ls legislation
litigation
we'd still be in the 1960s doesn't that
describe every sports league
in america though and the lawyer for
this case yesterday the austin versus
ncaa case as you know is our friend
jeffrey kessler
and jeffrey's the prominent sports law
attorney in the country he's represented
the nbpa the nflpa the tom brady case
the u.s women's soccer he's a four
letter word to many nfl yes he is
owners but he's still after it and he'll
be that guy
when brett kavanaugh says bring it on
he'll be that guy
to bring it to bring it and he wants it
all
what he wants is take all the
restrictions off let the free market
decide
now would that mean that trevor lawrence
was going to make several million
dollars if that was the case to join
a new a school four years ago probably
would that where would that money come
from and what would it restrict and
there's my confliction if that's a word
because
then we're talking about what about all
the minor sports
the money's got to come from somewhere
and jeff would say to that and i've had
him
interviewed on my podcast he said well i
would kessler your friend jeffrey
kessler would say to that
well they can just pay the the nick
saban's 10 million instead of 12 million
or they cannot have water slides at
clemson or they cannot have normatec
boots by every locker
you know but then you get back to the
arms race because if clemson
doesn't do it someone else will so
this is where college sports has become
as i keep saying this
two-tiered system you have college sport
basketball and football at
a level that's unbelievable and i have
you know villanova
we're we're big time they're telling me
what kentucky's doing what
north carolina's offering i'm like oh my
god you know we got to compete with that
because you want to get the best players
it's all about the players so
uh what what next what next i mean
so because it takes a while for someone
to bring it
to the supreme court and is the ncaa at
least realizing that
or or congress realizing that that
something needs to be
codified and then set in stone
and the ncaa does not appear to be the
organization
that should do it or has the capacity
to do it to figure this out like get
smart people
in a room to figure out what this
construct
is because the last thing you want is
the supreme court to make a ruling and
then all of a sudden the next day
you know recruiting seasons open right
right i mean so what happens now so i
mentioned
two words legislation litigation the
litigation we just talked about
legislation we talked about the six
states there are more to come for nil
maybe even before july one
and then you get to federal so federal
we've seen bills
cory booker's got a bill marco rubio's
got a bill anthony gonzalez former nfl
players got a bill it's bipartisan
it's politically popular whether you're
republican or democrat
right now we saw 9-0 in the supreme
court how often do we see that
and they're the conservatives were most
vigilant for student athletes
so i think one of these bills will
coalesce
now will it be a bill that the nca likes
like the rubio bill seems written by the
ncaa
or will it be a bill like the the cory
booker bill which goes way beyond nil
into health benefits and pension i like
all the collective bargaining stuff
we'll see that will be something to
watch now before we get to the next
brett kavanaugh bring it on
supreme court case i think we'll have a
national bill
and even with everything swirl around
this country it has taken on momentum
there's all these swirling bills in in
congress and joe biden has given some
modest a modicum of support towards
getting this done as well well
here's one thing i don't want because i
do want athletes to get what they
deserve
yeah and i do want somebody who blows
his or her knee out
in a sophomore year and have the
trajectory that could wind up
professionally
blown out and i do want health care and
i do want something
set up for athletes i do want that what
i
don't want and i don't think anybody
else who might agree with what i just
said
wants is to have where you're using the
trevor lawrence name because he's as
famous and as generationally talented as
a an amateur
athlete is or we've seen in zion i don't
want to see those
guys go to a school and then become a
free agent for other schools in the
middle of their eligibility
that i i don't want to see that
professionalized
environment in the collegiate
level yeah and i don't know if that's
possible right like where
you sign a letter of intent there's no
transfer portal or you can't use the
transfer portal to get more money from
another school
right can you see something like that's
i'm already seeing like that could be
the way this eventually winds up going
certainly when you do
have a generationally talented person to
basically say well coach you pissed me
off screw you i'm in the transfer portal
and i'm willing to take one more year of
eligibility
and and and go somewhere else right
i mean don't you think something like
that could happen i mean this is the
debate
and i've been on some committee
discussions with the big east conference
where let's tuck in io
what is the value of the name on the
jersey
so if a player on duke or villanova or
alabama or clemson
makes x in nal what would he be making
if not for the name clemson duke
villanova
et cetera this is where it's hard to
quantify
the value now listen zion not trevor
lawrence because there's no option but
zion could have gone
g-league for 100 grand or whatever
whatever the max was
200 grand but he chose duke because duke
has incredible brand value
so when we start talking about brands
and value you really have a
hard job extricating
value from the brand the college and
value of the of the athlete
will there be a free agency system i
don't think we'll get to that rich but i
do
worry as you do that with more rights
it becomes more professionalized
and you know we see g leagues we see
other leagues pop up
over time that's probably the future
but if you choose to go to college
you're choosing something different
than that you had a front row seat to
farve's drafting and roger uh i mean to
uh roger's drafting and and then the end
of of the farv
regime there uh how was rob what's your
recollection of rogers in the jordan
love role
back then what's your recollection of
that yeah i mean i've told the story and
we did this couple weeks ago
you know taking aaron when he felt us
you know all the guys we had raided
in first round grades were gone except
for one and all the combustion
in the room whether it take a guy that
wasn't going to help us right away
obviously we did he came in you know it
was a little bit frosty
having you know the two guys well we
have california cool
aaron and southern mississippi country
brett favre and brett was making
comments i'm not going to mentor it's
not my job
i think one of the things i feel best
about is over those three years those
guys relationship did warm
and it warmed to a nice level obviously
brett retired he came
back it was a messy divorce but before
that those two really did
start getting along well aaron was a
backup quarterback
you know aaron was a young guy coming
into green bay
from california he babysat my kids you
know he was dating a local girl in green
bay it was just a different kind of
experience
being a backup quarterback to of course
where he is now is completely different
level
uh rye's sense of humor never seemed to
take anything too seriously
as you've seen just has a nice way about
him to just be
calm relaxed and when that whole storm
went
in 2008 when brett came back aaron was
as cool as a cucumber
he really just stayed the core stayed on
task and he had
the emboldened nature of the
organization saying
we're not going back you have the keys
to this franchise
and yes 16 years hall of fame best
player in
history of the team was coming back
wanting his helmet
and you know i told you those that day
that mike mccarthy told brett those
three words
we've moved on that was poignant did you
know he was going to say that
yeah you did no we had moved on you had
moved on
and and what jordan love is going
through right now
is what gave us so much confidence about
aaron
in this in the off seasons of 2006 and
seven
we saw aaron run the team brett stayed
in mississippi as he does during the off
season i've seen his then were different
and aaron ran the team and i had guys
coming up to us greg jennings and james
jones and donald driver
like this kid can play like oh my god
yeah i know he's kicking play
i remember i was telling the story about
when he came out on that night in in
dallas when yeah yeah
when uh farvan versus romo and uh
i was electric it was electric and uh
one team was undefeated another team had
just one loss
yeah we were one yep and um and
farv got hurt and rogers came out we're
like well that's the end of that game
and
you know the game didn't go green bay's
way but
it was me mooch marshall falk and
sterling sharp
in the end zone watching rogers work and
after every throw we would look at each
other and go
oh oh my gosh holy crap he can play
can he it was a remarkable he came in
that draft week we had the mini camp as
everyone does right at draft week
and he came in first player first series
he rolls right hits donald driver in
stride like 65
yards ted thompson who had no reactions
to
anything his whole career locked eyes
somehow we locked eyes
and he gave me that look like we're good
we're good like we're good for the next
15 years
and the whole idea of taking jordan love
of course the packers fans i say this in
a in a
positive way they're the most spoiled
fans in the history of the sport
because they've had now 30 years of
franchise quarterback play and the whole
idea of taking jordan is to have 45
years of franchise quarterback play if
he's the guy
but that is something to have 30 years
of that andrew brandt here on the rich
eisen show former packers
front office executive so what do you
interpret the complicated fella comment
from mark murphy and how that informs
maybe the next several weeks
and how this plays out i mean listen
andrew
there's this there's a chasm whatever
word you want to use a fischer
between the packers front office which
includes mark
and aaron i don't know how deep and i
don't know what the
real foundations of it are i don't think
it's taken jordan love i think it's
bigger than that and i think it was
before taking jordan love you know
mark i think just wanted to appease the
group of season ticket holders or
whatever
high rolling packer fans that he was
talking to and just kind of threw that
comment out
i don't take it as strategic i don't
take it as directed
i don't take it as some kind of plan
to aaron having said that rich doesn't
help
doesn't help i mean and yeah and
invoking ted
who obviously passed away and ted didn't
say much but i'll say one thing about
ted
ted realized his shortcomings he was
elite a talent evaluator picked aaron
picked so many others
picked aaron against the world saying
you shouldn't be
karen um but he was not a communicator
he relied on me relied on john schneider
ready reggie mckenzie to sort of
communicate
with agents with players so he didn't do
that you know
it seems i i don't know who it is it
seems mark
is the communicator between the packers
camp
and aaron's camp it hasn't worked
i'm not sure if there needs to be
another voice or if there is another
voice
the frustrating part as we all know is
everyone asked what would you do well
i'd
get in a room i'd talk you know close
the doors lock the bathrooms but
it seems they've done that mark's been
out there
matt's been out there i mean uh
you know brian goodkin has been out out
here i'm sorry nelly
right yet here we are yet here we are
and the message they've given him what
sources have told me
is we love you we love you but
you know we scout we manage you play
and we're still at that kind of yeah do
you think the complicated fellow
because we just heard i'm trying to
square all comments
we just played again prior to this
segment andrew brandt
aaron albeit week two between weeks two
and three of the nfl season lot happened
obviously in the season and the way it
ended with
him coming off the field and brady
winning with a team that he just joined
after 20 years so he could see that
going elsewhere isn't the end all of a
career
it can actually be the birth of
something new but him
saying that he was at peace with the way
that he was playing football he wasn't
playing with a monster chip on his
shoulder he was at peace
is it possible that everything that went
down he was at peace before the season
knowing this is the end of it and that
he is going to be
the guy with the resolve to say skirt
you're going to you're going to mess
with me i will just
keep going and i will sit at home enjoy
jordan love
at the saints on monday night against
the lions against the
steelers on a sunday night in san
francisco enjoy it
yeah you go for it like could he be that
guy he could
i listen i don't think he will be but i
think he could here's the deal rich
i said the draft dave of jordan love i
said
two things i've never thought i'd say
number one we have an expiration date
on aaron rodgers and the packers
jordan love will play aaron rodgers will
play
15 years ago he is going to play this
idea that jordan loves going to be a
backup or he's going to flip
him for another first round no
the only question is when and i'm pretty
sure the packers plan was
two years erin set three two years so in
2022 we turn it over to jordan
aaron's like i was just mvp you want me
to do that again get you to the super
bowl and then
turn it over to the kid i'm not down
with that
what's in it for me so i think it's
about this control for the timeline
he's and i bet this feeling was like
just do it now 2021
right and they don't want to do it now
because the jordan love can't
play now and the draft choices that they
would acquire for rogers will only be
improved
well the story story broke on draft day
but you wondered like are they going to
get something done like right now
because that was the value well there
was also no
there was a cap the cap would have been
right i guess you could have made the
trade then and then
hope put everyone in bubble wrap to make
sure they didn't get hurt before june 1.
you know i mean
but it's 2022. and and that's what the
packers i think won we're going to trade
him in
march of 2022 and he's like
let's just do it now or the bottom line
is is he going to sit
i don't i don't see it
how do people get your newsletter andrew
dashbrandt.com i just sort of
want to do more content you know more
than my columns that sports illustrated
more than my podcast
direct people to some of the stuff i'm
doing it's been great you know it's a
way to me communicate
access that you don't have otherwise
andrew dashbrandt.com okay newsletter
and then your pod is
the business of sports yeah wherever you
get your podcasts it's good stuff
and there will be lawyers where did that
come from just put it out on twitter one
day and it sort of took
because there's always going to be
lawyers andrew i mean there will be
lawyers
there's one sitting in your chair right
here
um there will be lawyers no matter what
we talk about in sports and business but
sports even there will be lawyers well
and then and i appreciate you coming in
to give us heads or tails about what
happened
yesterday in the supreme court when do
you think the next case can come
how quickly because that's the time
frame in which something needs to be
either legislated or agreed to or
hammered out like that's the clock
that's now officially ticking kessler
yesterday yeah kessler's phone's
probably ringing off the hook for the
next case but
as you know it's got to go through all
the levels to get to the supreme court
correct
the better option is going to be
congress and then it's going to be
what kind of bill legislates college
athletics you know and is the ncaa out
you know where it becomes federal of
course well you know deadline spur
action that's another one of yours i
threw that out that's what i'm saying so
that
but when how quickly can a case come do
you think 2023
like i mean there's two years to fight i
think that's basically a time frame
about two years
meanwhile college sports will have nao
in six states at least maybe 10 by july
1st
ncaa's got to do something wow more of
these leagues especially basketball
are forming with the the the nfl and the
nfl pa
have hammered out everything that we're
seeing they've already agreed to these
things right
yes so then what what are what are they
telling cole beasley
from the from the players association to
say that they're still working on it
that it's not official
like he's cole beasley's saying that
it's not but it seems like it is right
it seems like it is it seems like
they're not telling you not to get
vaccinated because they can't do that
right
yeah or to get back right excuse me but
they're isolating
they're isolating those who don't get
vaccinated it's like we're going to put
you in the corner
until you're vaccinated and the big
issue to me rich is that
for cole beasley sam darnold kirk
cousins josh sweat
they've got job security
but you know it's going to be
logistically how like you raised before
we were on like
in the room out of the room if you're
josh if you're if you are
josh allen he was concerned uh
questioning that as well
if you're a quarterback and you're now
you now have to zoom into the meeting
where all your
fully vaccinated players are sitting
there in a film room we're watching this
and then
there's your starting quarterback on on
a screen
is that literally the way it may go i
would think
and not a player who's less who doesn't
have job security can you
think that's what i worry about with the
with the players association file a
grievance for a player who feels he's
been cut because he hasn't been
vaccinated i think good luck with that
because they agreed to these things
they agreed to these protocols i mean
i know firsthand in august those cut
down days
and you're going to have two three four
players equal
well this one's not vaccinated easy easy
done yeah out i mean we're gonna cut
sick we're cutting 30 guys in in
september first
yeah so the player who's on the bubble
and doesn't want to see the turk
should see the vaccinator they're
looking for reasons to cut guys
because everyone's so close it's you
know it's a fungible team below the
top 30. so yeah i worry about
that with the unvaccinated players so
again
if kirk cousins and josh sweat and cole
beasley
you know they're good but they have to
deal with these protocols
but you know unavoidable politics
it's happening andrew brant here on the
rich eisen show check out his work
on the mmqb the business of sports
podcast
and his sunday seven newsletter thanks
for coming on brother
my pleasure hey you watched all the way
to the end thanks for that
watch more right here